Nicole Priel, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
So great to have you.
I'm really excited
to do the show with you.
And I'm especially excited
to hear about your journey.
How you got into VC?
What does this mean to you?
There are a few stories
that I'm especially excited
to hear about
but let's just get started.
Nicole, tell me who you are
and why are you in venture capital?
Yes. So, I'm Nicole.
I grew up in London, Maryland, and New York.
And growing up in New York,
you start growing up really fast.
So, at the age of 16, while most of friends
were of being camp counselors
and whatnot,
I was working on the floor
of the New York Mercantile Exchange,
the commodities floor working for
natural gas and oil traders.
And that really propelled my career
into the world of investments.
So I went from there to a hedge fund
that was also trading oil and gas options.
Then when I went to university -
I have a question Nicole.
Why at 16 are you doing this?
Who at 16 goes and does this?
I realized that,
you know, you have to give it your all.
And if you really wanna get ahead in life,
you need to put
your best foot forward.
So, it was beginning
of experiential learning.
This whole concept
of learning outside the classroom.
And I wanted to build my resumé.
And position myself well career wise.
So, I was thinking already about
college and post college.
And I figured, all right,
I've done the camp thing
now it's time to move on.
Wow. Okay.
So, you're doing all these
sorts of internships.
What else have you done
leading up to college
and through college?
Not much else.
I was quite boring.
I volunteered a lot in New York.
I was pretty active
as a high school student at the time.
Israel was actually
in a tough spot with the second intifada,
so I was pretty active going to protests
and demonstrations and things like that.
Yes so it was a busy time.
I started the Zionist Action Committee
in high school.
And then I went up to Boston in 2005
for university.
And I continued on
doing interesting things.
I studied abroad at Hebrew U
when I was 19,
my junior year.
And that's where
I actually met my husband, by the way.
So, I fell in love at the age of 19.
Wow.
And set me up for the rest of my life.
But I came back to university
I came back to Boston in 2007, 2008
and I had basically
been exposed to this whole startup
Tech ecosystem in Israel
which was really nascent in the US
especially on the East Coast.
It wasn't really the thing it is today.
But I was really interested
in learning more about it.
So I discovered, lo and behold,
that Boston is a Mecca for VC.
So, I just shot off,
something like 24 cold emails
to all the VCs in Boston
and I said,
"Hey, I'm a student.
I wanna work for you.
I wanna get experience.
I'm happy to volunteer my time."
Two got back to me.
One said "We'd love to have you
but we literally don't have the space."
And the other said,
"You know what?
We're actually going through a rebranding
and we would love to have
a college student on board to help us do that."
So, that was
Flybridge Capital Partners
took a chance on me
and it was a great experience. So I -
24 cold emails.
Yeah.
I mean, at the end you're looking
and then you say
Okay. Not many college students
have an opportunity to work
for VC at that point.
And you could look at it
in the sense of,
Yeah, I got a position,
but then the backstory of there were
23 other cold e-mails that
either went unanswered
or were rejected.
It puts things in perspective on how much
you have to sometimes
just shoot for the moon
and hopefully something comes up.
So, talk to me a little bit about
your experience in that VC
and what were you doing there?
So, it was great.
I set up their social media pages.
I created their LinkedIn page.
They were undergoing a rebranding
so I was helping with a lot
of marketing efforts.
I sat in on pitch meetings
with brilliant entrepreneurs.
And I even did some due diligence.
There was an interesting company
that came through.
Two former executives
from Scott Toilet Paper
had an idea for a fertilizer company.
So I rented a car,
the only car they had on lot
was this red Dodge Charger
that looked like a sports car
but it's also used
as an undercover police car.
And I drove that down to New York
and I visited all these
home and gardening shops,
places like Home Depot.
And I was inspecting all the different
fertilizers and speaking to salespeople
and customers about their
fertilizer options.
So, that was really, really fun.
And it set me up well to do
VC post university.
So okay so you're finishing university
and you decide you want
to continue doing the VC life.
So, what happens next?
Yeah so actually, I graduated in 2008.
I don't know if you know
what was going on in 2008
but it was not a good time
to graduate university.
Much like today, it's not a good time
to graduate college in 2020.
So, I got a job at Exxon Mobil
'cause while the markets were down,
oil was sky high.
It was at $140 a barrel.
So, things were moving there.
That's a little different than
the free barrels we had the other day.
Yeah, yeah.
Crazy how fast things change.
And by the way, that's why so many energy
oil and gas traders blow up.
They just you can have a good year
and then you can have a bad year and
be totally wiped out.
So volatile. Yeah.
Yeah. So, I went to work for Exxon Mobil
in a management training
program for two years.
And from there, I moved to Israel
and rejoined the investment world.
Wow. Okay.
So, investments.
At the end of the day,
obviously, I mean,
it's fun, it's luxurious,
you get to meet a lot of entrepreneurs,
but why choose the investment route?
You know, I get to experience
some of this VC world here in the
early stage fund J-Ventures.
And it's so, so exciting,
but I can see both sides to it.
So, why are you so attracted to this world?
You know, I'm gonna tell you
half joking, half serious,
I'm in love with babies.
Since I was a young girl,
I was obsessed with babies.
There's something that's
so cute about them.
And I've always been a huge fan.
Once they're one, not so interesting.
I let my husband take care of them.
Give me them for the first year
and then they're all yours.
So, startups for me
are like babies.
They're honestly like
babies. My youngest
now is one.
So, she's in that not cute category and -
I heard that it's the terrible
twos that count.
I didn't hear about,
I thought you have two cute years.
I guess not.
Not in my book.
But when you're helping companies
from their very earliest stages.
From their inception, grow.
You pick them up when they cry.
You show them the way.
You hold their hand.
You give them advice.
You open doors for them,
literally and figuratively.
It's very similar to helping nurture
small babies.
So, I love cute babies.
I love exciting startups
and it really gets me going
waking up every morning
and thinking about
how can we help grow
this business today?
Or who is the next exciting entrepreneur
or company to come out of Israel?
So how many deals
would you'd you say you've been
a part of over the years
and over your experiences?
How many entrepreneurs have
you had a chance to deal with?
So, I have been working
in the investment field for
over 10 years now,
and I've seen a lot of different stages.
Late stage public equities.
Pre IPO growth companies.
Early stage.
And at IBEX,
we also, we invest across all those stages.
Over the years, we invested in
23 Israeli companies since 2012.
We've had seven exits.
So, really stellar returns.
Wow.
And we're actually
doubling down on Israel.
And just yesterday we closed
our second Israel fund.
Wow. Congratulations.
Thank you. Thank you.
We're really excited to double down.
That's amazing.
So, you're Vice President
at IBEX Investors.
What is this group
and what is sort of the thesis
that you guys go with?
So, believe it or not, back in 2011,
the founder of IBEX,
this guy from Denver, reads
the Startup Nation book,
gets on a plane, comes to Israel.
Does a little trip here.
Gets back to Denver and says,
"Wow, we've got to do something in Israel.
The innovation there is out of control."
So, they started with a really small fund.
Today, it's multiples of that.
And they just start investing
in public and private Israeli companies.
And we have the name, IBEX.
A lot of people don't know
what IBEX are,
especially Israelis which is ironic.
But if you're familiar with Yael
the animal.
- Animal?
Yes. Yes.
Of course.
The animal down south
around ...
That is able to to climb almost
90-degree angles.
Something amazing on the hills.
There you go.
So, most Israelis don't know that.
They're like, "What's IBEX?"
Then we say, "Yael."
And they're like, "Oh okay. Cool."
So why, but what is it about the animal
that's exciting and that reminds of
the entrepreneurial spirit perhaps?
The founder of IBEX likes to joke that
we didn't name our fund IBEX
because it's an exotic, elegant animal
who's able to scale difficult terrain.
We named it IBEX because
it was the first name
of Freddie Mercury's band.
Joke. Joking. Joking. Jokes aside.
Okay. Amazing.
So, how many people are part of this group?
We're 21 people
with offices in Denver, New York
and Tel Aviv.
Incredible. And so, you meet
So, is your position in Israel
do you just meet all sorts of
interesting startups
from all sorts of stages
and then bring it back to the group
and decide together
whether to invest or not?
How does a committee actually work?
Yeah, that's basically it.
So, I meet lots of companies.
Nowadays, it’s mainly on zoom
and that's cool.
But we can move really fast.
We meet companies.
We conduct some due diligence.
We do have an investment committee
where we decide if this is a go or no go.
With the last investment we made,
we met the company
just before covid broke out
or as covid was breaking out
in the world.
And we did the deal on lockdown.
So, we move very fast. From the
first meeting 'til the term sheet
it was 10 days.
So, despite the miles between
myself and my partners in Denver,
we move pretty quickly.
No I think it's actually it's interesting.
And quite a few people have been
telling me that a lot of these things
have been accelerated due to Covid
because now if people were waiting
for a physical meeting in the office,
a lot of the times they said,
"Okay. We don't have to wait next week
until we're all in the same location.
We can just do it tonight over Zoom
and get things rolling."
So, I've actually been hearing this
quite a lot.
But, you know, I'd love
to hear your perspective.
So you've been observing
the Israeli ecosystem for the past
10 years, I'm assuming. Right?
And I'd love to get your insight
into what have you observed
about the Israeli ecosystem, perhaps
in comparison to other ecosystems?
And I mean, I'm asking for myself
because I don't know enough yet
and it's fascinating to me.
Yeah, it's a really good question.
I did not spend time in Silicon Valley,
but what I can observe from Israel
is that the ecosystem here
is incredibly collaborative.
Everyone really lends a helping hand
to everybody else.
So, you don't have those competitive,
stealthy maneuvers
where people are trying to outbid
or outmaneuver someone else.
So, it's very collaborative.
Very open forum for discussion
with other funds.
We share deal flow.
We share ideas.
Founders are always willing to
help younger founders and mentor them.
Why do you think that is?
What is it about, why does the Israeli ecosystem have
this collaborative nature?
I mean obviously I love Israelis.
I'm Israeli myself.
And it shows on the street and on the beach,
but I would imagine that when it comes to
venture capital, to entrepreneurship,
I mean, there's only so many good deals
out there and there's a lot of VCs
who are looking for them.
It's David and Goliath.
We're a country the size of New Jersey
that's mainly made up of sand
trying to break into the big old
United States of America
where there's tons of capital throwing.
Tons of tons of interesting people
and startups that are coming out.
And we need to
literally cross mountains
and oceans to get there.
So, whatever we can do
to help each other succeed
Like someone else's success is my success
and likewise.
So, I think we're up against
a great challenge and we need
everybody's participation
and cooperation to surmount that.
And is your decision to focus primarily
your efforts on the Israeli ecosystem,
is that out of any professional strategy?
Or is that mainly your love for the country
and the fact that you made
aliyah for that?
It's a mixture of both.
So, we have ... fiduciary duty.
We return capital to our investors.
Israel's a great place to deploy capital
and to be able to get those returns,
those venture style returns
that we're looking for.
Personally and professionally,
it also obviously strikes a chord
in my heart to be a part of it
and to help that.
So, given that you've been
practically a Zionist
since high school
and leading these efforts.
I mean, it definitely shows.
Talk to me a little bit about
some of the things that you've observed
with the young entrepreneurs
versus maybe serial entrepreneurs.
That's always a fascinating topic for me.
What does it mean to,
you know a lot of people
give so much credit
to serial entrepreneurs
because they've gone through
different things.
What have you been observing
and what type of entrepreneur are
you most excited to work with?
So maybe this is a bit unconventional,
but serial entrepreneurs, they're great.
And yes, they have the experience.
They've been through the whole cycle.
They know the ups and downs.
And when they come up to bat
to do it again,
it says a certain thing about that person
that they know how tough
and grueling it is
and they're willing to do it again.
And that's phenomenal.
But when we look for invest,
when we look for founders to back,
we're actually looking for the ones
who don't have that experience.
Who have a chip on their shoulder.
Who feel like they have something to move
and they're determined to make it big.
Wow. So, you're actually
on some way preferring
a first-time entrepreneur
rather than a serial.
Obviously, every deal on its own,
but overall, you're more excited
about these first-time entrepreneurs.
Yes.
I've never heard that before.
Amazing. Okay.
And, you know,
But with the chip on the shoulder
comes the lack of facing the
adversities and the lack of experience.
And so, you are foregoing
all that experience for the passion,
the motivation and that
initial excitement.
Yeah, that's true.
So, it means there is a little bit
more handholding.
And we learn from our mistakes.
We learn from our mistakes.
But we are prepared
to roll our sleeves up
and help them out.
And I think that they also
have a lot to teach us.
So, we're happy to give them the chance.
We're not stubborn about,
second timers.
Right. So, I mean,
and also this idea of being
an active investor versus
a passive investor
and sometimes holding hands
and being there for them.
How much of that meeting
alignment of expectations is there
before you go into a collaboration
with an entrepreneur?
Or how much understanding is there between
the two parties on how much or how intensive
this relationship is going to be?
Because it can go all ways, right?
Totally. Totally.
And you never know until you jump in.
It's a massive leap of faith.
Massive.
And that's why so much of it comes down
to the team and the chemistry between
the investor and the founders
because you're literally spending
day in and day out with each other for
five, 10, maybe 15 years even.
So, all those expectations should come up
in the beginning with the understanding
that things can change
and things will change.
So, gotta just hope for the best.
And is that something that you can
reasonably aim to really understand within
a matter of 10 days due diligence?
I mean, that's very fast
for the responsibility of aligning
expectations and realizing if this
is gonna be a good relationship.
Yeah, well 10 days actually sounds
like a lot. When you think about it,
you develop like an intuition
and a gut instinct within the first
10 minutes of meeting someone.
So you know pretty much
from the outset whether this is something
that could potentially work or not.
So, compare that to the next
10 days of due diligence.
It's the 80-20 rule.
So yeah, sure I could spend three months,
speaking to every person
who's ever encountered the founders,
but is that really going to make
a difference in terms of our decision?
Probably not.
Right and I think one thing that I've been observing
is that more and more funds are taking
ownership over this fast, this quick
decision making. NFX famously did
that over covid and Fusion Labs in L.A.
also, three weeks until a deal.
I think 10 days is extraordinary.
But it sounds like also this is a greater
incentive now for entrepreneurs as well
to trust the VC.
And do you think that is because
there are more VCs now looking
for the great talent,
which is scarce
and it needs to be more attractive?
Or is that really because the VC wants
to be more efficient and see
more deals throughout the year?
Is it the chicken or the egg?
I don't know if I'll ever answer
that question sufficiently.
Definitely.
You're right that there's more
and more companies today,
not necessarily
all of them are venture appropriate.
There's this misconception, I think,
that if you want to start a company
that you need to go out and take venture.
And I feel very strongly that venture capital
is not the model for most
businesses out there.
So, there's alternatives
and entrepreneurs need to keep that in mind
that venture capital is not
the mold for everyone
and for every type of business.
So, they shouldn't really necessarily spend
a lot of time chasing venture capitalists
if it's not appropriate for them,
and they can speak to a couple people
and verify that pretty quickly, I think.
And depending on the VC,
Yeah, efficiency is key.
We're looking to do three
to four investments a year.
So, we obviously have,
there's a lot of deal flow in the pipeline
and when we meet the ones
who we want to work with,
we can move very quickly.
Right. It's fascinating to me
this work that you,
you spend so much time
meeting so many people. At the end,
what it comes down to
are these few key investments
that you make on a yearly basis.
And when you say 4 investments a year
it doesn't necessarily sound like a lot,
but when you put it in the context of
seeing hundreds of companies
and going through that,
going through that filter,
which has to be really, really precise
because at the end,
this is the fiduciary responsibility
you have towards your other investors.
I think it's just an incredible journey.
Nicole, right before we leave, I have
to ask you the most important question.
Three words that describe you.
Oh my God. Wow.
The first things that come to mind.
This is not a huge commitment.
All right.
I always live by the mantra:
You never know.
Explain that. Explain that to me.
So many people are afraid to take a leap,
afraid to make a change,
unsure of what's to come.
And I say, "Hey, you really never
know what's gonna be.
This could turn out to be the best
decision of your life"
Or you think that you're gonna do X,
but it's gonna turn out to be Y.
So, nothing is certain.
And just listen to the
New York Lottery
that was their motto.
You never know.
I think it's awesome.
And I think it's probably one
of the best mindsets you can go in
to the industry that we're living in
because you just never know.
And every day I'm surprised by something
new that's happening.
And I think that's just what makes it
so exciting.
It's the unpredictability,
and it's the fact that literally
anything is possible
and you never know.
Nicole toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you for your generosity
and have a fantastic day.
Thank you.
It was a pleasure speaking with you.
Take care.
Bye bye.